welcome back to the rich eisen show uh
the subject matter of this segment and
the interview
we're about to conduct is very sensitive
in nature
um and i i say this uh
just as a heads up certainly to any
parents out there if there are kids in
the room because it is summer break if
there's anybody
um who's uh of a certain young age or
something like that who might
potentially be disturbed by the
conversation we're about to have i give
you that fair warning a heads up here on
nbc sports
on peacock and this um rich eisen show
radio affiliate but it's an important
subject matter and again it's very
sensitive
certainly when you're talking about
sexual abuse um in a sports program
and i i talked about this just a couple
weeks ago when
the subject matter certainly um
was uh laid bare uh involving my alma
mater which makes it very sensitive for
me personally as well
that if i'm going to be on the show
talking about this subject matter when
it happened at penn state
with a football coach or at michigan
state and ohio state in the big ten
as it happened with doctors at those
facilities and
those institutions of higher learning in
the big ten then i'm
i'm going to be consistent and talk
about it here on the rich eisen show
and in that vein in that mold is
how i bring in my next guest who reached
out to me
wanting to talk more about what he
talked to sports illustrated about in a
very moving
article with the cover story being jared
bunch doesn't want to tell you this
story but he will
and he's now here on the rich eisen show
somebody who was on the team that i saw
from 86 to 90 when i was on the campus
and then spent many years in the
national football league as well jared
bunch here on the rich eisen show how
are you jared
uh rich i'm doing all right you know i
i'm
i'm good i'm good you know just this
situation is not
something that i enjoy but
me talking about it has brought a lot of
uh i'm hoping to bring a lot of clarity
and it's also
people have been reaching out to me and
um thanking me
for doing something i just thought i was
you know i'm just
telling the truth of what happened and
i'm not the only one that's
you know this is i would say 80 of the
guys that went to university of michigan
all went through the same thing i mean
we
that was a that was the way he did a
physical period
he being dr robert anderson who was at
the school at the time and
you know um i i like i said part of
one of the many reasons why i wanted to
talk and have this conversation with you
jared is is because so many people that
i went to school with and
and and and um
at the time as well as since want to
know what to
think about all this and what to believe
and what to understand and what to
what to comprehend and and take in so
i'll i'll give you the floor on that
as to what did happen to you and what
you want us to know about
jared what what you know the way i look
at it
is what happened to me was what
happened to all the players the football
players that i went
was playing with from my years from 86
to 90
91 when i left university of michigan we
all went through the same physical
if you saw dr anderson he did the same
type of physical
he did a rectal exam he did um
you know check your for prostate and
and did all these other things that we
had never been through but
my first time going there it was it was
this
it was a discussion you know the guys on
the team older guys all talked about you
know all right you get ready to go see a
you know doctor drop the drugs you know
that was it i mean it was
it was not like a something that you got
into a big surprise
everybody went through it it was just
something that
it was the physical and
i didn't even know that it was a
difference until i got to the pros
when i had a physical with the pros it
was i'm like that's it
oh okay you know um
that was and that was it i mean that was
the atmosphere
at michigan was you know if you're going
to see him you can drop the draws
well and some people might be hearing
this jared and thinking
well shouldn't a doctor be checking for
for prostate cancer
um even though obviously that sort of
stuff doesn't
usually manifest itself until later in
life but
you thought that the the the manner in
which the physical was being conducted
unnecessary is that
is that what you're saying after i
at the whole time that i'm at michigan i
didn't i i never had any
physical like this so i didn't know i
thought that was
the way physicals went and the talk
from all the players and and well prior
to it and after and everything else
was you know you're gonna you're gonna
stick your finger you know stick your
finger in your butt and
you know that was the talk um and he
gonna have you doing this and he gonna
have you doing that
before you get there you get in there
everybody was talking
you know what what to expect so
that was the physical that was what we i
i understood and everybody
else understood i just found out that
everybody didn't go through that
and when i say everyone i'm saying that
everyone was talking about the people
who i was around
that would be running backs and offense
and the freshmen we when we came in as
freshmen we had our own locker room
we stayed together because we they
wanted us to grow up together
that's what we you know that's what we
talked to and that whatever
upperclassmen
that you were around that's who you got
your information from or what to expect
so we became those upperclassmen after
the first year
and this was every year the physical was
the same
you do that and you you tell the guys
you know what to expect now sometimes
throughout the year if you had to go
back and see him for whatever reason he
was always
it was always you know basically you go
in there you don't have to he don't ask
you
until you drop the jaws
even if even if what you were going for
did not re
you know was was not uh he'd he'd say
that to you even if you had like an
upper body injury or something like that
so what you're saying that that that
that's what i'm saying
so jared bunch here on the rich eisen
show so
did you ever or anybody else ever
complain
to the coaching staff that what's going
on with the doctor
is something that is uh making you
uncomfortable did you ever
communicate something like that or you
or any of your teammates ever
communicate any something like that to
the coaching staff at the time we had
discussion i never had to go
and say um i never once said
uh a complaint because it seemed
for me to see him i personally had
things
with the groin or stomach or something
that it made sense that you have to drop
but as i'm saying that i've
come out guys are now telling me man i
used to go up for a headache i go there
for a concussion and i go there forever
but on that i'm saying to them how come
you guys are not saying anything now
even though i came out i know i'm not
the only one
why aren't you guys anything and they
don't want to
rock the boat currently not want to look
currently not want to look
currently is what you're saying you're
saying currently that's the current
i'm saying currently since since since
this has come out since
the article has come out guys have been
all comment calling me emailing me
texting me
they don't it has become a
this us against them you know it's more
like athletic department versus the
academic department or younger players
versus the older players
some of the older players let you know
they don't want
they don't want bowl's name to be
tarnished this morning you know because
people now they're talking about
um taking his his statue down and they
and they're like
no i don't think beau knew about it even
though we are and it's exact words
even though we all went through the same
thing i don't think both knew so
if they're gonna try to get their statue
taken down all that
i don't wanna be a part of that i don't
think he knew
so it becomes this
yeah it happened but i don't think he
knew about it so
i don't want to create new problems
jared bunch here on the rich eisen show
from the university of michigan 86 to 90
as well as uh the national football
league
um after that and he was um subject of
uh the sports illustrated article does
not want jared bunch does not want to
tell you this story here
on the rich eisen show do you this is
the ultimate question then because again
this is what
i get asked all the time and um
do you do you think that beau
schembeckler knew that
um some untoward activity at the very
least was happening
uh in the medical room with the
physician that had been on
staff for all those years jared this
this is this is where how i answered
that
i never told him but
when i look over the course and i look
at the
the wilmer hill report back in 1972 bo
was told
that anderson was doing some things to
players
and bo told the player to go
see the athletic director he told me to
write a letter and see the athletic
director report
that plato reported it back in 1972
about anderson so it was reported back
then it was going on since then
did i ever say it and not like i said
like players don't want to get involved
they don't want to talk about it they
don't want to say
because no player ever said hey
well i can't say no player ever but i
didn't say it
the culture was you were not bo didn't
want you
in the the medical staff he didn't want
you seeing the medical staff he want you
in the training room he didn't want you
around it so that was
that was it so that part
i understand why no one said anything i
ain't saying that because i didn't want
to say nothing
i thought it was that was par for the
course that was it
everybody's getting the same thing so
it's nothing to say what am i saying
am i looking like oh everybody's getting
it but now i'm the one that's
complaining
i'm when this off that
that was that culture that you didn't
want to say anything and
like today right now players are like
nah
yeah we all went through but if they're
going to turn us his name
i don't think he knew well he didn't
know because none of us said anything to
him
but from 1972 he knew
what anderson was that's what i had the
problem with
i didn't know you know when i got to
1986 i didn't know
the past i didn't know dr anderson's
past and what he had been doing and what
he had been
uh accused of and what the report says
he was doing
the wilmer hale report is referring to a
an
investigation that that michigan has uh
had um
wilmer hale i guess until a law firm
conduct
uh an investigation of this and that's
how you're referring to that jared so
what do you want what do you want all of
the alumni base to know
because again like i said when you know
i've known you for a long time you know
we went to school together i rooted for
you together i covered beau's final
season there
i talk about what being a michigan man
is and a michigan man is
is being there for for someone else and
you you were
reaching out saying hey a lot of people
are
you you've been getting a lot of people
asking you to appear in places right so
hopefully this right this will be that
one time and you don't have to do this
uh any more than you want to um so i'm
here
and for for the rest of the alumni base
what do you want everyone to know and
what do you hope to have come out of all
of this
what i'm surprised about is how michigan
has
has taken this and not tried to make
everybody holding let's close this thing
out they have dr dragged this thing on
they have now made the players
against the academics administration
it's it has made players split the
players
and those who think they need to support
both
and those who think that they just need
to tell the truth
it's a split i i talk to you about you
know having conversations with
other players with group we have in
group chats and whatnot and it's all
it's split because they don't want no
one wants
to get bo
bo's name tarnished but the truth has to
come out and if the truth comes out
and in some way it makes his name not
look as well as
there's some place that we think that
bow would be look
if i have to take the hit
then i have to take the hit to get this
thing fixed but let's not
tear each other apart
and still not have anything taken uh
straightened out when it's all over now
his name is torn down this is torn down
the statue turned out and we still
didn't get nothing situated nothing
straightened out still there's
what happened who's they still believe
in both sides
the bottom line is the man was a monster
the and i say the man dr anderson was a
monster
he was a he did sexual things
that he should not have been in the
position now why he was in that position
was it the administrative was athletic
director
was it the head coach whatever the point
of this matter is he was there
and they all knew about his past
except the players we didn't know
we didn't know about his past but we
went through all the things so
if we would have known about his path
when we went in there and he did those
things
we were like wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute no no
no no and we would say something
we didn't know how can you expect for
21 20 19 year olds for the first time
coming from like my small town
what physical that we have what kind of
physical do i go through
it wasn't all this when i got there got
to the university of michigan this big
time
university of michigan got all these all
the stuff going on all the
the best of the best what am i supposed
to think about when i get the
the exam that i'm getting that's what
the best of the best gets
how about what do i have it to compare
to nothing
but when i got to the pros and saw the
difference i understood but it already
had been in my mind
of what the doctor part
is in the program he's for the program
he's gonna do whatever
he has to do to make sure that you do
what the program needs you to do so when
i got to the pros
the same thing i'm thinking that the
doctor is just for the franchise
even for me it's not for me
[Music]
so what i think is go ahead no no i just
want to um
get to what what the message you want
for
everyone to know and how you think this
is going to play out because you're part
of a lawsuit correct and
how how does this all get handled to
your satisfaction do you think
jared bunch number one you know
they're gonna have to accept the
responsibility
they have to expect accept
responsibility for putting them in the
position and putting all the players all
of us
in the position that we had to be in to
see this man you know we did not
we they could have chosen anyone they
could have put anybody in that position
they chose him and i'm talking about
1986 was
14 years after they first got a report
about him
and he stayed there how many years
afterwards
they were come on the responsibility is
on them
that goes wrong that goes for
administrators
and the coaches are it's all they all
knew
we didn't know they were their actions
changed
all of our lives and how we see
administrators as how we see the coaches
how we see
they formed our expectations of
every person that we dealt with from
that point on
jared i hope um this conversation was um
was what um you know what you're hoping
for looking for
anything that i could do to you know
like i said um
it's a very difficult subject because
it's a family matter for all of us at
michigan right
i mean like we're as you point out your
a lot of your
your your colleagues and teammates were
are
are you know hesitant to discuss their
experiences um because of it and
you know you and i have conversations
about how much you know
uh michigan holds a place in our lives
and i speak on behalf of a whole
um alumni base i would like to say that
we're
we're we're hoping for the best out of
everything right here
which that that that's what makes me you
know that that's the hardest part for me
is that i because of
of of my i graduated from michigan
and because of the things that i've done
on this did on the football field
it gave me a chance to do a lot of other
things in my life
a gay if i had not graduated from
michigan
played at michigan i don't know if i
would have been living in beverly hills
i live in beverly hills california i've
had
you know a career in nfl in
entertainment
i've had a lot of things good things
that happened
they and that's why it's hard for me to
talk about
because it's not like i want to erase
all that
but i cannot also cannot just overlook
what things have happened and could have
been
avoided if they did the right thing so
now
it's to me they should be trying to fix
it
get the things right let's all right
let's figure out how
can we fix this that's not what they're
doing now
that's not what they're doing now
jared driving this thing dragon thing
out jared i appreciate the time
let's connect down the road you've got
my number let's
let's keep in touch thank you thanks
rich you bet that's jared bunch right
here on the rich eisen show
you